today's news is all about positivity
and what better way to focus on the
positive than an entire newspaper
dedicated to good news
yeah that's right this is the happy news
a british publication dedicated to only
good news in the world look how great
this is i mean come on
i grew up with pages of magazines lining
my walls like wallpaper
in fact i actually make a zine it's true
i'm not just all
words i'm action um
so the news team that i work with they
brought me this paper
they put it to my attention because they
know that i'm obsessed with good news
and now i'm
obsessed with the woman who makes this
i'm kind of convinced she's my british
soul sister
and here to talk about her newspaper the
happy news
please welcome emily cox head
i think the best introduction i've ever
had
oh my god well i could have gone a lot
more psycho overboard i kind of had to
tame down because i've
like i'd feel like we've been separated
at birth
i i really do i mean you love happy news
i love happy news
you have an amazing design blog with
your boyfriend
that i totally love i was you know
scouring the instagram account
and i just love what you're putting out
into the world it's something i really
subscribe to i did it i said it
that's right can i ask you since
i'm just meeting my soul sister for the
first time why did you create the happy
news i i don't know i was struggling
with my own mental health
and i think the two things that were
impacting it the most
were social media and the news and i
sort of began to realize that
it was having that same effect on far
more people than i realized
and so when i started looking for the
good and then sharing the good things i
then noticed the positive effect it was
having on
both me and other people and now
it's i think it's just needed i think we
just need to
not in a world that's full of overwhelm
i think we should be hearing about
the kind people and you know the amazing
thing
things that happen in the world that we
just don't hear about do you have any
tips
for digesting the realities of the world
because we can't ignore them
what do you do i think i think notice
the impact it's having on you for a
start i think be mindful about how
you're feeling
when you've read a newspaper when you've
been scrolling through social media or
any of those things i think you've got
to look hard for the good things but
they are there
and you've just yeah you've just got to
look a little bit harder than
what's on the surface i get on a feeder
and i'm it's not it doesn't always make
me the happiest person i feel really
informed and up to the minute
but it's true it it it depletes my
my battery my energy my hope
yeah yeah that's that's the biggest
thing and that's what i've said from the
beginning of the newspaper
i i want to give people hope and i want
to
i want people to realize that there are
good things
um it's it's a really weird balance
because obviously whenever i've done any
sort of press things you sort of get the
people who are like
it's so naive or you're sticking ahead
in in the sand
and i never want to try and cover over
the bad because and pretend that the
world's just full of sunshine and
rainbows because
it isn't um and i always try to
acknowledge that what you are doing
with your paper is you're giving your
lens of the world
and we need this emily keep it up let's
stay
the soul sisters that we are if i may
interject myself into your life that way
see i told you it was gonna get creepy
emily thank you
so much i'm so happy to know you thank
you news crew for bringing us together
can we please hang out again definitely
thank you so much for having me
i'm with you let's keep up the good
fight
all right moving on okay our next story
this really spoke to me as the animal
lover i am it turns out that a bunch of
endangered species
are making a comeback and the good news
network has a list of animals who are
almost extinct but are absolutely now
thriving
like the four-eyed turtles now they
actually
don't wear glasses because they would
slide right off they don't have ears
the world wildlife fund says that tigers
are also making
a big comeback and that's in south asia
russia china fantastic work tigers yeah
because you always want to be on the
good side of a tiger i know because i
greet one every morning
when i bring out the hairbrush to my
daughter i almost lose my face and hand
in more animal news it's been reported
that mount rainier
has had its first wolverine sighting in
over a hundred years
no not that wolverine i know but
a mama wolverine and her two baby
wolverines were spotted prowling the
park
and i'll tell ya a family of wolverines
i get you
i see you i avatar tale with you because
i'm going to show you a picture that i
show to people when i'm trying to
describe the mother i
am with my children i'm a doberman i'm
protective
you feel me all right so here at the
news we'd like to say a big welcome back
to all the endangered species
we missed you moving on this study is
about social media
the feeder we're all on and guess what
there's some good news
a study from michigan state university
says social media can actually promote
happiness as long as you interact with
it and you don't just
doom scroll hashtag doomscroll
hashtag stop so just like in real life
we should all foster a sense of
community
and that includes me i'm committed to
spreading happiness all the time
across all the show's channels and we're
going to even kick it up a notch
so go to drewberrymore at
drewberrymoretv
and interact with us and we'll interact
with you and then we'll all be happy
because
it's science baby
oh you know one thing that really does
mean everything to me here at this news
desk
is to try and connect with people and
sometimes telling the stories around the
world and other people's stories
is a way that you and i as strangers can
come together and know
that something positive is happening in
the world that life
is worth living that good things are
happening
and to me that's as newsworthy as any
news you'll get today